from britney spears to harry potter he
is one of the all-time heroes right but
now daniel radcliffe is playing a
villain opposite sandra bullock in the
lost city and on a press tour he he got
hit with a huge question he says they
asked who are your three biggest
celebrity crushes right and people
reports that while he's in a very happy
10-year relationship with actress aaron
drake he was willing to name names so we
have them right here his top three
celebrity crushes are juno temple
cameron diaz and drew barrymore
yes
harry potter's hot to trot for you drew
that is crazy it seems like he has a
type
but um i was googling him and his
girlfriend um and they're just so lovely
um i um i this is so fun i mean it's so
fun to like
name like i i don't who would you pick
rossy for celebrity crushes yeah oh i'm
glad you asked okay let's start i
i am currently i'm really into andrew
garfield right from tick tick boom and
uh eyes of tammy faye you know what you
called him a walking jawline i did i
can't get it out of my head now yeah
he's jawline goals for sure and then old
school crush for me with ac slater mario
lopez thank you very much
and do you know who my first celebrity
crush ever was
are you ready who um aladdin thank you
very much i remember
i was
i was on a date
i was i was like in eighth grade seventh
graders on a date with amy taylor you
know who you are and um she tried to
kiss me and i was like amy do you mind
i'm watching aladdin
vest on that carpet
that's true
well my one of my first crushes um was
darth vader i think oh i know i know i
know you're all gonna be like what
you're so twisted i
i used to have this reoccurring dream
about him when i was a kid and it was it
had definite sexual understanding
that is so weird
wow i think we all can agree like
sometimes the mask is hot yeah
and uh maybe i had daddy issues i
diagnose yourself um as i grew up
i definitely gravitated always towards
funny men yes you know like david
letterman of course you know and um
funny enough because i like funny men i
got interested i was like you know what
would be so great is a dating app for
people who like humor well it turns out
the boston business journal reports
smile is a dating app that matches
people by sense of humor really yes
it's developed by melissa mullen and it
launches april 15th now here's how it
works instead of
swipe on profile pics users
users will rate funny content from tick
tock and instagram and then an algorithm
will match your sense of humor to people
who laugh at the same things that you
find funny it's like funny bone to funny
bone yes um and the
um
and the app also plans to blur
profile picks it first so that you don't
get a full view of someone until you've
been chatting for a bit like it's humor
overlooks
i mean
what do you think
i i'm really into this jaw lines will
sag right but
lols are here forever and i think you
have in your relationship you have to
find the same kind of stuff funny or
it's just not going to work you know
there are days where wellington and i
will just text each other back and forth
with just memes no words but on tuesday
he sent me a meme of a guy in a mankini
holding tacos dancing like this
and i knew that meant we're going to
mexican food that night say no more
that's all i need
that is couple goals that is couple
goals thank you true uh i have to say
i'm really looking forward to this
dating app thank you for putting it out
there in the in the world and um i can't
wait to see how it works are you gonna
join it and maybe
maybe someone else out there likes darth
vader and giggles
[Music]